while nearly every olympic games draw
some form of controversy the 2022
beijing olympics could take the gold
medal a number of countries announced
diplomatic boycotts of the games over
concerns about what the u.s has labeled
genocide in china foreign spectators are
already banned because of china's zero
covet pandemic strategy even mbc the u.s
network airing the competition will be
originating some broadcasts from its
connecticut complex where 84
commentators are feeling the heat over
what they might say on air that could
anger the contentious country so why
choose china for the games multiple
european countries dropped out of the
running to host these games leaving just
two countries to choose between china or
kazakhstan neither has a great
reputation when it comes to human rights
human rights watch said last year that
kazakhstan is a country where torture
occurs with impunity and violence
against women and girls persist as a
serious problem meanwhile u.s secretary
of state anthony blinken has accused
china of genocide and crimes against
humanity for its treatment of the uyghur
ethnic minority china has the money to
put on a big show but the human rights
concerns make things awkward for people
trying to do business there without
angering customers back home billionaire
investor shamath pali hapatia took heat
last month after dismissing concerns
about the plight of the uyghurs
tesla ceo elon musk was criticized for
opening a car's showroom in the region
where the uyghurs have been forced to
live and organizations like the nba have
backed off from badmouthing a nation
where they see dollar signs
and covid will complicate everything
again
just two weeks ago about 20 million
chinese were in lockdown a very
effective lockdown according to
government officials who reported zero
deaths from the virus in the country
last year but olympic organizers have
detected more than 100 covet cases among
athletes and personnel in the last week
and this year's games won't feature the
usual frenzy of on-site deal-making for
athletes and marketers thanks to strict
govet 19 protocols and a very limited
number of spectators being allowed in
the competition venues most companies
won't be flying employees or vip clients
to china the athletes will bear the
brunt of the cancellations as they miss
out on easy opportunities to connect
with potential sponsors
some good news the event might keep the
dogs of war at bay
former president barack obama's
ambassador to russia said that despite
the country's growing military buildup
along the ukraine border the immediate
threat of all-out war between the two
nations will drop sharply after friday's
opening ceremony
so
let the games begin